send you one of my videos that was
released on my instagram two days ago
where i call the police and i tell them
that we have armed settlers
wandering around our streets and
screaming death to the arabs while they
are armed
and they are being protected by the
police and 911 told me
we don't owe you nothing and they close
up you have it you have it on my
instagram recorded
and before even but what about his point
uh tamiya what about his point sorry to
interrupt you what about it
yeah but it's really important that the
whole attitude to us and the definition
will be
we are not arab israelis we are
palestinians who are living inside of
israel the war palestinians for us is
very very important because it's our
identity
there you go but equally i was going to
put his point to you
that synagogues are being destroyed
and uh israeli jews have been attacked
so
again it is not one way is it none
no none there is no buildings in in
general there is no buildings or or
synagogues or mosques or churches
uh that should even even even people
that should be harmed in general this is
something that all the world should
agree on but the problem is
if you can watch the videos you can see
how they are how the israeli side there
is more violence from the israeli side
and they are backed by the police i have
videos i wish i can send you the videos
that you can see them throwing rocks
while the israeli police is protecting
them so the message that we are getting
here is clear
we are under attack and we are not
protected
this is the message that we are getting
and of course there will be no
um there will be no trust
with with such such an institute
well i was going to ask you what is the
chance of
your community trusting um the police
again in the near future oh
trusting this whole institution of
course we can trust this institution as
long as they apologize for
what happened to us since 1948 from
kicking our grandfather taking our lands
demolishing our houses you know
apologizing for what we did was is a
great way to start a new dialogue by
apologizing and admitting the crimes
this is a great way to start a dialogue
but again we have this evening tamir um
the police saying that
uh a police vehicle was rammed and that
led
to a shooting of uh the driver so the
incidents go on
and the incidents are both ways when
will this come to an end
this whole both ways thing i understand
it happened instantly both ways but you
need to understand that
all you need we need to go not to the
reaction but we need to go to the source
the source
that the israeli government especially
with this new right wing it's been
provoking the palestinians
it's been stealing the houses and it's
doing everything so it will be very very
very naive for us to stand and say
why is it happening it's like throwing
for it's like lighting a fire and we say
why is it hot
it's it's it's if you want to fight if
you want to find a solution
even the media itself you should stop
comparing us as both ways you cannot say
both ways
we don't have an army we don't have arm
we don't we are not armed
we are not stealing lands we are not you
need to understand it's not cool to be
symmetrical and it's not fair you need
to know which side of the history you
are standing with
but equally equally you've got to find a
way
to resume living together
side by side that's the only dad do you
know
do you know what i would love that how
would you say that to the people who are
being kicked out of
how would you say that when you have
settlers backed by the cops saying
that this land is for our this land is
only for the jews when the horn when the
main anthem is this land is only for the
jews that you're only ignoring the
christians and the muslims
and then you say live together how how
would you live together
imagine you living in the uk or i don't
know
imagine even america saying this land is
only for the whites it's literally
saying that and then you say how come
they don't want to live with us
the title is saying we don't want to
live with you the title so i don't think
you should ask us
right right and just briefly
um 30 seconds or so tamiya how do you
see the next
week or two weeks playing out
i don't know i know by myself that i'm
going to kick some ass with songs
and i'm going to protect with my only
arm that i'm the with the weapon that
i'm holding which is my microphone
and this is what i'm going to do